Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker: And
he said Houston I do love it is exactly what
I'm looking for is this exactly what
we need but the fact of the matter is
I am not going to take something to my
boss that's not based on a book because
I don't want to put my job on the line
for you that's exactly what it told me.
Film Courage: Why don't we
see new ideas in Hollywood?
Houston: I think it's because of risk I think when
you look at the risk analysis of feature films or
or television the the there's a hesitancy
of taking a chance on a new idea you have
to you have to think about Hollywood as not in a
vacuum where there's all these middle managers in
Hollywood they're all executives right and there's
there's there's a hundred people that that are all
involved in everything in the decision of what
to make and what not to make and and by and
large people don't make those decisions based on
what is the what's going to propel the industry
forward creatively and what's going to be you know
that what what does the artistic integrity of the
of the industry need and like they're not asking
those questions they're asking the questions of
what can I do not to get fired from my job and
you know if it's a lot easier for these executives
to to say no to something that could potentially
be risky than to say yes to something that could
be potentially risky and it not work out and all
of a sudden they get the blame because they took
the risk I mean if I'm a studio executive and I
have two scripts in front of me and one is this
really hip interesting progressive edgy you know
uh script that really pushes boundaries in a
really interesting way that's a lot of creative uh
edgy interesting things and then I have the reboot
of the brady bunch as a feature film starring
vince vaughn as greg brady which actually sounds
sounds kind of good but the but if I have that
in front of me and it's like solidly mediocre
right but um if I have those two things in front
of me the most artistically interesting choice
the new is the new idea let's let's promote
new ideas let's not go back to the well in
the brady bunch right um but 99 times out
of 100 what's going to happen is going to be
we're going to make the brady bunch not because
we think the brady bunch is going to be better
or one it has pre-awareness in the market
right so it has a community of people that
already know what the brady bunch is even if
you don't haven't seen an episode of the brady
bunch odds are people have heard of the brady
bunch and so there's this market awareness that
that shifts the risk and they think it's a safer
bet and because it's the safer bet they think
if I push my chips in on the brady bunch and it
gets made and it doesn't do as well as we think
I still be able to keep my job because I
made the safe decision but if I go all in
on on a completely original idea that that is the
more artistically interesting idea and it doesn't
work guess what who's on the chopping block me
for making the bad call right and listen it may
not be my fault maybe other people's fault but
you know everybody's kind of shifting the blame
everybody wants to blame somebody in in and and
especially on the executive level you know it
's you could only lose 50 million dollars to
somebody else's money so many times before they
don't give you 50 million dollars to lose anymore
right and so it's tough that decision to green
lighter not the green light but that's not made
in a vacuum they they sit there and say how do I
you know how do I keep my nice six-figure
salary with my premium health insurance and
how do I keep my kids in private school and how
do I keep my wife not having to work and do the
things that she likes to do and how do I keep my
house and my gated community and how do I keep
you know the the two cars that I have and like
what are the decisions that can preserve that and
I'm gonna do those because then if
I do those long enough eventually
my boss will retire and maybe I get it
promoted and then and then becomes that game
and listen I'm not even criticizing those people
for doing that maybe I do that in the same if I'm
in the same situation I have kids I got a house I
got a wife like I got dogs I got things right so
and I don't want to get fired we need health
insurance like there's all these other pressures
that come in but but if you if you now if you
now look at the entire industry as an industry
that is motivated not on artistic integrity
but how do I keep my job that really clues
you in of why we don't see a lot of new stuff
that's why we see reboots that's and listen
largely reboots don't work we saw that with female
ghostbusters we saw that with the new terminator
movie we saw that you know we've seen that
every now and then they work right hawaii five-o
worked I think uh there you know there's some
that that 21 drip street I think worked actually
the times you actually see it work I think it's
when you shift platform if if it was originally
a movie then they turn it into a tv show or
originally a tv show and they turn it into a film
that usually works more than film the film or show
to show typically just as an anecdotal observation
but it's largely reboots don't work that
well in the industry just look at the numbers
so why do they do it 's because it's the safer
bet even though we know it's not a safe bet it
looks like the safer bet so when people come
to blame somebody I can say well no everybody
knew the brady bunch it's not my fault it's vince
vaughn's fault it's the director's fault somebody
else's fault but mine right so then I get a
stay in my gated community I mean it's really
interesting I mean look the the executives I was I
was talking to the with the um the president of he
had a really interesting comment he said you know
executives they they live in the gated communities
and then they leave their gated communities and
drive through the gate into the lot and then
work and then they drive back to their gated
communities and never go east of robertson
right and they live in this weird little bubble
that breeds a different mentality than you know
than the consumer or the audience or you know
when we're saying why don't we have any more ideas
it's not our money on the line right it's easy to
say there should be new ideas we shouldn't make so
many superhero movies it's not our money like
it's easy it's easy to say that if you're not
if it's if it was your 50 million or 100 million
dollars that you're actually putting on the line
maybe that conversation changes right because now
you're like maybe I don't want to take the risk on
the progressively interesting edgy psychological
thriller that doesn't have any pre-awareness in
the market maybe it will end up being one of the
coolest most artistic films that we've seen in
the last 10 years but we've all seen movies like
that not be financial successes this is when this
is how they turn in the cult classics right and
and we see movies and we're like how did that how
did that not work why does everybody see this and
there's there's a hundred reasons why a thousand
reasons why great films aren't commercial
successes and not being a commercial success
doesn't not make you a great film artistically of
course right but when it's your money on the line
it's a different story right and so and so
you have to and if and when it's your job
on the line when you're spending somebody else's
when it's your job to spend someone else's money
which puts your job on the line the calculation
changes right I think it's that's a you know I i
had I had a situation where I pitched a I pitched
a tv show to a studio and they were looking for
content for their their digital extension of
their of their network and they they told me
what they were looking for I pitched this idea
the the the to a producer had a had a pod deal
with the network and he said this is perfect I
love it this is exactly what we're looking for
and I'm super excited because I think oh well
this this deal's done this is great and he said
what what book is this based off of and I said oh
it's not based off a book it's an original idea
and his whole body language changed he like
slumped down and says oh yeah it needs to be
based on a book and I and I said no it doesn't
because you love it and you think it's perfect
and it's exactly what you need so we're good
right he said no needs to be based on a book so
is it possible that we could find a book that
already exists that is kind of like the idea
we can option that book and then say this idea is
based on that book and I said that's this is the
stupidest conversation I've ever had with anybody
in my whole life you said it's perfect you said
it's exactly what you're looking for you love it
what's the problem and he said houston I do love
it is exactly what I'm looking for is this exactly
what we need but the fact of the matter is I am
not going to take something to my boss that's not
based on a book because I don't want to put my job
on the line for you that's exactly what it told
me and I said I appreciate your honesty I really
honestly did like appreciate like that insight
I got it I expected this guy to go out on a on a
limb stick his neck out for an idea and an ip that
that wasn't established in the marketplace didn't
have any community built around it didn't have any
market presence it was risky and I expected him to
assume my risk which puts his job on the line and
and he didn't what he didn't feel comfortable with
that because he wanted to he didn't care about
the art I'm gonna say he didn't care about the art
he didn't just care about the art I mean
of course he wanted to make a good show
right but there was other considerations that
were very practical he wanted to keep his job
and we forget that we we forget that that in the
music industry the a r executives you know that
there's a lot of undiscovered talent that may be
better than other people but but all of a sudden
I'm gonna sign the tick tock star that is much
worse than this undiscovered talent because the
tick tock star has 12 million people that
follow the tick tock talk star on tick tock
therefore if the tick tock star washes out it's
not my fault because I took the safe bet rather
than I go out and pluck the undiscovered dude from
iowa that doesn't have any following he washes out
guess what it's on me because I took the
risk I didn't I i took a risk and I lost
and and so the calculation changes then this
is why this is why somebody like like jake paul
or logan paul they they can go out and they can
they can fight uh these these these named boxers
they can go out and fight floyd mayweather I mean
did logan paul fight floyd mayweather because he's
the the best most deserving boxer in the world no
he did it like he was able to do that because it
was a safe bet like he had pre-awareness in the
market and then just made sense and so like it
just you know that's just the the the fact of the
matter of it right like it's just jake paul can go
and write a script and sell that script to a major
studio faster than 99 of independent screenwriters
in Hollywood right now that are 19
000 times more talented than jake paul
no offense to jake paul he may be a closet
screenwriter I'm not sure I don't think he
is but but you get what I'm saying is is it's not
because he's better it's because he's safer and
and the executives know that the executives
know that and and they can they don't think
that jake paul will write better stuff but they
think if they bet on jake paul rather than you
if jake paul doesn't work they can keep their
jobs so we always as creators as filmmakers
we always have to understand the business of the
business and understand the very human calculation
that is going on in the executive level or the
investment level or the people that are behind
the desk it's not these decisions aren't made
in a vacuum it's not just what's going to make
the best movie unfortunately that's not
the case anymore right maybe maybe it was
back in 1977 maybe it was a different mentality
that went into executives but today's executives
it's a high-stakes high-pressure environment
and and there's there's real careers on the line
there's real families that rely on real salaries
and and we just think we just think well as long
as our concept's right and as long as our
three-act structure works and as long as
our character development's right then if if if
I if I am able to execute the art the right way
then then they should make my idea and just it's
just and then you get frustrated when they don't
and then you see crappy movies that are released
that are reboots and you're like oh where's the
original ideas just a more complicated very human
calculation that's going on that's different than
the calculation you think is going on well and
people are voting with their dollars someone's
seeing it whether they're the ones that are also
leaving a gated community to go into the gated
you know parking lot at the local cineplex
someone's buying these tickets and so
I i you know whether they whether they just
are checking their phone the entire time or
not and they're not really they're just going to
appease their their kids or their friends is to
not to be known right now but but so someone is
seeing these things sure that's the hard part
and and the ones that these art house films or
the these very unique edgy indie dramas whatever
um unfortunately they they're they're people
aren't always voting with their dollars to
show that they love that stuff sure and and
listen and you're right the market decides
the market decides what it likes and what it
isn't like and yeah and and that's the way
normal business works that's the way the world
works the market decides what works and what
does it and we can't just sit back and make value
judgments and say well my my movie was better than
that well if the market has decided that it's
not now artistically speaking you know that's
maybe a different consideration this is this is
the the difference between the oscars and the
people's choice awards or the just look at the box
office like really I mean they don't give out the
oscars just based the best picture could be what
was the highest achieving box office picture of
the year they don't do that they look at they look
at the art and there's artistic achievement that's
the focus of the oscars but really the the the the
red the regular the regular audience member you
know again I'm from kentucky we I don't you know
I'm not from the coast and now that I've been on
the coast for 15 years I realized you said it's
a different mentality when you're in Hollywood
you know people seen all the oscar movies and
they've seen all the all the the streaming shows
and all the deep cuts and they can you know but
you go you go to middle america you go to wyoming
you go to kentucky you go to ohio go to georgia
it's it's it's there you know people don't people
don't know the directors they don't know the dps
and they don't know you know all the the deep cut
indie films and they haven't seen you know david
lynch's third movie he made out of film school and
like they they like that but but when you live in
the bubble of Hollywood maybe new york right you
convince yourself that everybody thinks this way
and and you start making you start making stuff
for people in the bubble right listen
not saying that you just have to make
you know so the quote-unquote studio crap you know
the quote-unquote big commercial high concept film
you have to make superheroes all the time
there there are there is room for art but
but I think ultimately you need to figure out
how to marry art and commerciality that's the
there's an intersection that can happen and
when that happens that's that's magic I it never
never ceases to surprise me of how many filmmakers
fight for the right to be a starving artist
and they they they find pride in it
and I just I i can never understand it
I would much rather than be
well-fed artist still be an artist
but figure out how to operate in a commercial
environment where the audience will vote with
their dollars I feel like we have to find that
intersection you know something like a quiet place
was was I think in a good example of that it was
I thought it was a very well made interesting
artistic very very different choice of of how to
do a monster movie and very almost risky in a way
but it had commercial sensibility and it
worked and you look at something like ted lasso
I think you know ted lasso I i feel like is is is
a really interesting commercial success that isn't
game of thrones right like it but at the same
time isn't the office or like I feel like this
it's an interesting it's an interesting thing
if you look at what's going on in the emmys you
know the people that are cleaning up the enemies
it was you know the crown and the uh you know
queen's gambit right the queen gambit was a huge
commercial success but at the same time I think
was a a wild artistic success as well I feel like
it fit that intersection and I feel like that's
what a lot of independent filmmakers struggle
with is finding that intersection but because they
they you know they need to they need to think
outside the bubble um and listen ultimately
you got you got to make what's in your heart
and make what drives you and and sustained you
right and so um but it's you know it becomes
difficult when you're making stuff that that that
the market doesn't bear right and if you're and if
you're happy with that and you're fine with that
muscle top that's great but but ultimately I
feel like we need to figure out that intersection
and if you can again it goes back to that
pre-awareness conversation if you can figure out
how to take that interesting super artistic you
know edgy ip if that people don't want to touch
because it's it's too risky if you're able to
establish that in the market in three or four
different ways or even one way like you establish
as a podcast and it pops to the podcast and now a
hundred thousand people subscribe to that podcast
guess what it's the same edgy progressive artistic
character drama idea but now all of a sudden the
studios are going to now be more apt to take a
a take a gamble on that original idea because you
were able to establish in the marketplace first
right so I think you know that approach really
really benefits people that don't just want to
make superhero movies or marvel movies or zombie
movies or vampire movies or whatever you know the
big genre flicks or whatever it is they want to
do some different artistic interesting things
even more these people have to embrace all the
tools in the toolbox they have to figure out how
to establish in the marketplace let's let's prove
the audience and once we can prove the audience
then all of a sudden these people that were that
were nervous about taking taking a flyer on it are
are going to be a lot less nervous because they
see that you've proven yourself in the marketplace
I had an investor that said that that told me
every single movie that is pitched to him he
he he has the filmmakers go he said he'll
he'll invest if he decides to invest
he will only invest 80 and it's 80 finishing
funds and he makes the filmmakers go and raise
20 the first 20 of the budget on kickstarter right
and and it's it's one I think he's tested on the
horsepower of the filmmaker but really what he's
looking for is you need to prove that there's a
market you need to prove to me that there are
people that will actually get behind this thing
and if there's people that actually get behind
this thing guess what okay cool i'll come up
with the the other eighty percent but you gotta
you gotta generate the market first right and so
so I think if you are one of the filmmakers
that have the edgier non-commercial idea
then you have to figure out a way to get that
story and that ip to as many people as you can
aggregate the data and the analytics of the
audience and then use that to soften the risk
analysis that was was was probably well against
you that was working against you but now you
can shift that now to potentially depending on the
success to actually working for you in a great way
and and two with with the queen's gambit as as
sort of edgy and artistic as it was walter tevis
had already proven himself with the hustler sure
and and and then it's the man who fell from earth
and I'm not sure how all that fared but so there
were there was a succession of of of successes I
guess you could call it and so if if it had just
been an obscure screenwriter who wrote the exact
same thing sure would they have taken a chance on
it as amazing as it was well this is this is what
they tell you when you go when you go shop shop
a a script that's non unbranded content right
they'll say um they'll say you need to go package
this you need to find attachments to this and you
need to go find an actor that will say i'll act in
this or you need to find a director that says i'll
direct as a producer that says i'll produce this
and if you get the attachments involved now all
of a sudden they may take a chance on an original
idea that's unbranded that's not based on anything
else because they're getting the pre-awareness
from the talent rather than the ip right so and
so yeah if you can get you know if you can get
julia roberts to say hey I'm in or get michael
b jordan said i'll i'll i'll be in that that'd be
great or you know you get you know the rock to say
i'll i'll i'll produce it and star in it right
if you can get that then the game changes for you
the problem with that the practical problem with
that is it's difficult to get attachments it's
hard you know talk to any agents and and like you
know the agents will tell you they'll say you know
that their clients have scripts they're the the
people they rep they have a stack of script that's
taller than my seven-year-old that they're waiting
for them to read to decide what to attach to
yeah and then that's the ones that actually get to
them right but it's how do you get to these people
right how do you how do you like for the for
the the mere mortal filmmaker how do you get
to michael b jordan how do you get your script to
michael b jordan especially if you're unrep now
if you're if you have a manager or an agent then
then you expect your agent to figure out how to
connect with their agent and make the submission
and things like that but especially if you're if
if you're unwrapped it's like it's it's in your
impossibility unless you you know seem at a club
and you know you get in the conversation or or you
know your your sister is friends with his cousin
and you know one of those weird gotta know people
to know people type of thing right that Hollywood
works you know with a lot of ways but it's hard
to get those attachments I had a a buddy who is
a professional house sitter for celebrities when
they go out of town like he's licensed and bonded
as a as a as a house sitter which is you know
god bless america that that can even be a thing
but but so he goes out and you know he um uh these
celebrities go to town he'll stay at their house
feed their dogs feed their parent things like that
and then and then you know there's somebody there
in case they get robbed or you know they think
they won't get robbed if somebody's in the house
so but he was telling me that he was at he was he
was staying at um that at a at an actor's house
who was an a-list actor in the 70s late 70s um
now is older probably a c-list actor you know at
this point not you know doesn't do a lot of stuff
but used to be you know everybody knows him his
big name right and he and he told me he said he
would receive courier packages of scripts and he
would open them up take the script out open up a
room and throw it in and there was this huge pile
of scripts there that this guy was supposed to be
reading through in order to decide what to attach
to what's going to be your next movie right and
and it's just like so frustrating for writers and
and because we're writing this stuff and we send
it out and we just we we're we we think okay the
rock's gonna read this and I'm just waiting for
the rock to get back to me and tom hanks is gonna
you know maybe be in my movie maybe not right but
at the same but now you know it's it's 150 scripts
before he'll get to your script and who knows
when that is it's a hard game to get attachments
right if you can get attachments great
but but I like to now say I'm gonna
I'm gonna now approach ip in a way that um that
I'm going to presume I don't get any bigger
attachments I'm not going to I'm not going to
not try to get attachments of course you attempt
to get attachments but I'm going to presume I
don't and so that if I do it's gravy it's not
the entree I'm not betting on it right and so I'm
going to try to attack the market and build the ip
with pre-awareness as much as I can with the
mindset that i'll never get attachments so that
I can skew the risk analysis myself through the
congress the aggregation of the of the audience
and then if jennifer lawrence decides to be in the
movie then even better it's gravy right it's it's
the icing on the cake not the cake itself right
but but that shows you the pre-awareness has to
come from somewhere it's either coming from
the talent or it's either coming from the ip
but it has to come from somewhere right unless
this is this is my eternal caveat to that horror
movies horror movies are this really bizarre
exception somebody like jason blum can can can
they can make a horror movie with nobody you've
ever heard of with a director you've never heard
of with a story that's never been been established
in the marketplace and and you can still make
those movies and they can still make money at the
box office and horror movies defy all those rules
for whatever reason um which is interesting the
horror genre is very specific about that if you
come up with a concept that's great and the
visual concept that goes along with it and you
know figure out like a wildly creative way to kill
people and things like that then then you can you
can still you can still get that stuff made so
so which is great for the horror for the horror
industry everything but the [ __ ] outside of
the horror industry operates on pre-awareness in
a major way I actually like that idea for a movie
that the house sitter and that the guy goes in and
starts reading these scripts because he's bored he
has all this time he's supposed to stay there and
then he starts writing himself he doesn't take
anybody's ideas but he just starts he says you
know what I want to do a screenplay and he gets
made I love it that would be that would be awesome
yeah you should write that okay maybe I don't
know just establish it check with your friends.
Do
you agree with Houston? What is your reaction?